the hydrogen Club has been a dog
training facility located in downtown
Las Vegas for the last nine years but
the owner says she can no longer
compromise safety to continue the vision
that entrepreneur Tony Shea once had for
this area nine years ago today
I stood right here
and announced the opening of this park
it's a full circle for hydrogen club
owner Kathy Brooks hi Buster he said
Brooks on delay entrepreneur Tony Shay
met in 2012 when they decided to open
the private dog boarding and training
facility as part of the downtown project
this was a dream
that I didn't know that I had
that
the blessing that was Tony Shea giving
the downtown area a new vision from
crime and grime to thriving businesses
he would walk by and there would be this
Oasis that gave everyone a sense of calm
and peace in the middle of Fremont
Street but Brooke said recently the
homeless have taken over making it
nearly impossible to get through her day
safely I've had rocks thrown at my head
I've been spat on I had someone throw a
drink at the fence at me but the last
straw was during an overnight shift at
the facility at about 10 10 15 I'm awake
into the sound of gunfire right outside
the wall against which my head is
resting just this weekend someone broke
off their doorknob I have clients who
stopped coming down here they're like I
don't feel safe downtown anymore good
boy is It ultimately Brooks wasn't sure
she was safe anymore which meant she
couldn't jeopardize the safety of the
dogs the hydrant Club will close its
doors on December 31st until then it
will remain open every single day so its
members can continue playing and say
goodbye to their friends
Victoria Saha 8 News Now